오늘은 한국어와의 어려움에 대해 이야기하고 싶습니다.
다양한 언어를 어떻게 배웠는지,
어떤 과정을 거쳐
성공했는지, 왜 그리고 어디서
어려움을 겪었는지에 대해 이야기하고 싶습니다.  한국어,
아랍어를 포함하고
오늘은 왜 한국어에 대해 이야기하겠습니다. 제가 한국어를
처음 접한 것은 1972년이었습니다.
오래 전 제 아내와 저는
일본에 살고 있었습니다. 우리는 한국을
방문했습니다.  단지 그것을 보기 위해 나는 아시아
대륙에 있는 국가가 기본 구조에서 교착 언어의 북아시아 출신이라는 점에서 일본어와
어떤 종류의 언어 관계에 매우 관심이 있었고
물론
중국어의 경우 지루할 정도로 지루했습니다.
한국과 일본 모두에 대해 알고
있고 중국으로부터 엄청난 문화
차용을 받았기 때문에
관심이 많았습니다. 한국이 개발도상국으로 간주되었을 때 좋은 방문이었습니다.
그러나 지금 우리가 알고 있듯이 한국은 정말 발전하고 있었습니다.
1976년에 다시 방문했을 때 좋은
친구가 있었습니다.  캐나다 대사관에서
결혼한다고 하더군요.
결혼식에서 내가 들러리가 되기를 바랐어요.
한국 여자와 결혼했어요. 그래서 저는 그때
한국어 공부를 위해 책을 몇 권 샀어요.
한국어를 배웠지만
별 일을 하지 못했습니다. 당시 살던 일본으로 다시 돌아갔습니다. 그리고
1980년에 한국을 방문했습니다.
캐나다 원자력 에너지 회사에서 일하고
있었습니다.
한국은 캐나다가
한국에 원자로를 건설하고 있었기 때문에
결국 저는 캐나다의 원자력 에너지와 1년만 보내고 다시
산림 산업으로 돌아갔고 다시
한국에 대한 초기 연구는
수렁에 빠졌습니다.  그래도 그것은
거기에 있었고 당신은
2003년에 내가 언어학자라는 책을 썼는데
그 당시 한국어가 포함되지 않았던 9개 언어를 배운 경험이 있었고
어쨌든 우리는 Link를 시작했습니다.
한국어로 돌아가야 해서
링크원에서 한국어가 없는
책을 더 샀어요. 매우 좋았고
한국어에 대한 소개가 정말 즐거웠어요.
제목이 '어'인 것 같아요, 내 책을 언제
보여드릴지 알게 될 거예요.  여기 브리티시 컬럼비아 대학교 도서관에서 진행한 도서관에서는
내레이터의 목소리가 너무 좋았고
어떤 학습 자료에서도 중요하기 때문에
지루한 내레이터가 나오는 이 초보자용 책은
나를 짜증나게 만들었고 그것이 바로 이 책의
가장 중요한 점이었습니다.  한국어에 대한 나의 열정
그리고 책은 패턴으로 가득 차 있었습니다.
언어 학습은 패턴에 관한 것입니다.
그들은 문법적인
설명이 있었습니다. 그들은 결합 동사와 같은 용어가 있었습니다.
이상했지만 나는 그 모든
설명을 무시했습니다. 나는 단지
패턴을 받아들였습니다. 패턴을 들었습니다. 일종의 대화를 듣습니다.
반 유머러스 한 대화 학생들은
제가 어느 정도
익숙했던 상황을 문화적 전통에 대해 너무 무겁지 않고 익숙하지 않기 때문에
더 어려운 일을했으며
그것이
제가 말하는 것의 최고점이었습니다.
한국어 공부에 열중해서
책을 더 샀는데 점점
이 책들도 지루해서
흥미를 잃기 시작했고 그
때 러시아에 관심을 가지게 되었고
우리는 러시넷 링크를 갖게 되었고
곧 베리안이 백미러에 들어왔습니다.
그리고 나는 러시아어에 모든 시간을 보내고 있었습니다.
러시아어에 많은 시간을 보냈습니다.
매우 흥미로운 내용이 있었습니다.
정치 내용, 문학 오디오북,
좋은 내용이 너무 많아서 링크에 포함되어 있었기
때문에 러시아어를 배우고
그다음 체코어, 그 다음에는 다른 언어를 배웠습니다.
비록 제가 한국어를 다시 시작하기 위해 정기적으로 노력했지만
2010년에 여러 차례에 걸쳐 제가 괜찮다고 답한 제 통계를 보여드리면 여기에서 보실 수 있을 것입니다.
3개월만 투자해야 할 것 같습니다. 90
일 챌린지 제가 무엇을 할 수 있는지 알아보세요.
내 한국어 실력이 더 좋아졌고
향상되었거나 향상되었다고 생각하지만
물론 오랫동안 사용하지 않았습니다.
마지막에 선생님과 한국어로 대화하는 영상을 보여드리겠습니다.
90일 동안의
챌린지 중 일부를 다루었지만 여전히
여러 가지 이유로 링크가 어려웠습니다.
초급 콘텐츠가 있었고
이야기가 많지 않았으며 중급
콘텐츠는 별로 관심이 없었습니다. 제가
시도한 것은 팟캐스트를 찾는 것이었습니다.
실제로 누군가에게 돈을 지불하여
이 팟캐스트를 복사할
수 있도록 했지만
매우 어려웠습니다. 하나는 문학
팟캐스트였고 다른 하나는 정치
팟캐스트였습니다. 저는
이 팟캐스트를 헤쳐나가기 위해 노력했습니다. 너무 어려웠기 때문에 알 수 없는
단어가 너무 많았습니다.  물론 한국어에는
8개의 가능한 의미를 가진 작은 단어가 너무 많아서
어떤 의미가 적절한지 몰랐고
지금처럼 문장 번역을 구할 수 있는 문장 보기도 없었습니다.
그 단어의 번역이 정확했습니다.
오늘 링크드에서 한국어를 어떻게 번역하는지 보여드리겠습니다.
단어를 검색한 다른 사용자가 더 많은 종류의 사용자 힌트가 있다는 것을 알게 될 것이며 가장 가능성이 높은 힌트를 빠르게 확인할 수 있습니다.
단어를 번역하고
문장을 보면 의미를
더 잘 이해할 수 있습니다.
링크가 느려지기 전에는 어떤 것도 사용할 수 없었기 때문에
힘들기 때문에
역풍이 너무 많았기 때문에
너무 어려웠기 때문에 항상 그랬습니다.
다른 것에 끌리니까
다시 생각해보면
한국어에 대한 나의 열정이 최고조에 달했던 것을 다시 생각해보면
셰익스피어의 율리우스 카이사르의 인용문에서 브루투스가
인간사에 밀물이 있다고 말하는데,
홍수에 빠지면 이 흐름이
이어질 것이라고 했습니다.  성공이라든가 등등
내가 가장 열광했을 때 계속했더라면,
어려움이 덜했더라면,
더 흥미로운 콘텐츠가 있었더라면,
링크가 더 잘 작동했더라면,
사전이 더 좋았더라면,
이 모든 조건들이
매력이라면
내가 계속해서 더 나은 수준을 달성했을 것이라고 생각했던 것보다 더 컸고 저항은 적었지만
한국어에 쏟은 모든 노력은 손실되지 않았습니다.
내 통계에 따르면 이론적으로 알려진 약 40,50,000개의 단어가 있습니다.
이제
이 모든 언어는 우리가 어떻게 세는지에 따라 달라집니다.
단어
한국어에는 단어 어미가 많이 달라서 도움이 됩니다
문장에서 단어의 기능을 정의하는 데 도움이 되므로 어
다른 언어와 비교할 수 있는 것은 아니지만  나는
어휘력은 물론 이해력까지 갖추고 있고
중국어도 물론 도움이 되기 때문에
한국에 가더라도
자유가 없다면 가족이 있고 다른
일도 할 수 있습니다.
두 달 동안 한국에 가서
사람들과 함께 있고 항상 한국어로 말할 수는 없지만 그렇게 한다면
괜찮은 수준으로 끌어올릴 수 있을 것 같지만 그럼에도
불구하고 실망스럽습니다.
1973년에 처음으로 한국어 책을 샀으니 꽤 오랜
시간이 걸렸습니다. 나는 그 책들을 오랫동안 갖고 있었습니다. 나는
한국을 위해 많은 노력을 기울였습니다.
내 책장에 있는 이 책들을 펼쳐 보면 여러분도 알게 될 것입니다.
밑줄과 체크 표시, 그리고
온갖 것들이 있다는 것을 알지만, 당신은
당신이 고의적으로 배우려고 하는 것이 아니라 지금 페르시아어에 대해 가지고 있는 것과 같이 계속해서 유지할 수 있는 의미 있고 흥미로운 콘텐츠가 필요하다는 것을 알고 있습니다.
언어를 즐기기보다
언어를 배우고 나면
언어를 즐길 수 있는 곳에 가면 진행이
느리더라도 재미있다.
한국어가 즐겁지 않은 곳에 가보니 일이었는데,
일이 되면 알겠더라.
성공하는 데 필요한 시간을 투자하기가 더 어렵기
때문에
링크에서 제가 한국어로 작업하는 모습을 보여드리고
그 후에
약 9년 전 제가 나눈 대화에 대해 제가 말한 비디오를 시청하실 것입니다.
90일
챌린지 중 하나라서 한국어를 포기한 건 아니지만
오랜 시간이 지나서
이루고 싶었던 것을 이루지 못했어요. 들어주셔서 감사합니다.
일단
안녕히 가세요. 보여드리고 싶어요.
어 어떻게 공부하는지 알아요 여기 링크로요
컴퓨터 버전을 사용할 거에요
제 아이패드에서도 할 수 있어요 여기 보시면
한국어 페이지가 엄청나게 좋아져서
이제 여기
문학 오디오북에서 선택할 수 있는 콘텐츠가 너무 많아요 uh  복근
운동 어 알다시피
다양한 것들이 시작되죠.
우리는 이전에 한 번도 해본 적 없는 미니 스토리가 있다는 걸 알죠.
그만큼 훨씬
낫죠. 콘텐츠
측면에서 보고 싶은 수준을 선택할 수도 있지만
저는  예를 들어보겠습니다.
제가 찾은 것은
YouTube에서 가져온 것입니다. 이전에는 불가능했던
항목을 YouTube에서 가져올 수 있는 기능이 생겼습니다.
라이브러리에서 찾은 강의는 다음과 같습니다.
YouTube에서
직접 찾을 수 있지만 어쨌든 이걸 클릭할 수 있으니
유치하긴 하지만
여기에 가면 괜찮을 것 같아요. 그러면
해당 문장에 대해서만 오디오를 들을 수 있고 개별
단어를 찾아볼 수 있습니다.  이전에는 할 수 있었지만
훨씬 더 빠르기
때문에 이러한 모든 다른 의미를 가지고 있습니다.
우리는 여전히 최상위에 있을 가능성이 가장 높습니다.
이제 번역이 표시됩니다.
문장이 더 많아지면 여기서
외국
콘텐츠를 볼 수 있지만 방법을 보여줍니다.  콘텐츠를 가져오는 기능을
소개하면서 링크가 개선되었습니다.
이것을 보여드리겠지만
MP3 파일, 전자책 강의를 가져올 수 있으므로
가져올 때 자료를 가져올 수 있습니다.  오디오
전사 속삭임 AI가 나에게
스크립트를 제공하므로 여기서 교훈을 만들 수 있으므로
사용할 수 있는 콘텐츠 유형이 너무 많아서 여기에서
선택한 팔꿈치와 같은 웹 사이트에 가면 전체 경험이 훨씬 더 편안해졌습니다.
한국에도 홍수가 났어요.
이와 같은 홍수에 관한 기사를 선택하고 웹
브라우저나 브라우저 확장 프로그램으로 이동하면 해당 기사를 가져올 수
있고 링크로 연결되어 교훈으로 공부할 수 있습니다.
좋아요, 정보가 들어올 때까지 몇 초만 기다리면 됩니다.
이전과 비교하여 변경된 것 중 하나는 신문 기사 등에서 YouTube의
브라우저 확장 프로그램을 사용하여 클릭 한 번으로 가져올 수 있는 항목이 엄청나게 많다는 것입니다.
레슨을 열면
레슨이 있습니다.
파란색 텍스트가 많이 있다는 것을 알 수 있을 것입니다. 이것은
알 수 없는 단어입니다.
페르시아어로 알려진 단어가 약 13,000개 있는데, 링크에서 무언가를 가져오면
다음과 같은 내용이 표시됩니다.
페르시아어에 훨씬 적은 시간을 소비한 새 단어가 훨씬 적습니다. 훨씬 더 많은 것을 이해합니다.
여기 보세요 파란색 단어가 두 개뿐입니다. 페르시아어의 경우에는 알 수 있습니다.
내 전체
숫자로 가면 알 수 있습니다.  저는 2018년부터 이 일을 해왔고
알려진 단어
추가가 1,000개 정도 되는 최고점과 같습니다. 그리고 그것은
대부분의 경우 최고점입니다. 시간이 얼마나
흘렀음에도 불구하고 제가 한국 상황을 보면 그보다 훨씬 적습니다.
내가 그 돈을 쓴 것은
2010년으로 거슬러 올라가는 것을 볼 수 있습니다.
지금은 4,000개의 알려진 단어가 추가된 날도 있습니다.
중국어를 아는 덕분에
한국어로 앞으로 나아갈 수 있습니다.  그리고 점점 더
많은 알려진 단어를 추가하겠지만
여전히 어려울 테니
그냥 일하고 일하고 아무데도 가지 않는다는 느낌이 더 커졌습니다
uh 페르시아
달걀
껍질이 아닌 한국어로 예
음
[음악]
차가운 음식